对 我觉得上周试试是挺刺激的
然后三蜜有一些N1
然后我说一下基本的几个看法
我看看怎么往下调
然后三蜜 其实我这个事情要回到将近一个月前
三两三个星期前
其实你回头看我们从3月31号超底
然后其实在5月初的时候淘宝
然后很多仓位淘宝没有全跑
然后但是整体的看法是这样的
就是当时那一轮主要是CTA在强制的买盘
然后把它强制买上去
然后接下去我们上周也讲了
接下去一段时间大部分的三蜜的上涨
其实由于三方面原因造成
第一个就是本身三蜜这些公司的估值都会压得比较低
比方说英伟达吧
英伟达他业绩增长了百分之七十几
然后但是就一年至到百分之七十几
那相对于去年的这个价格
那个时候的价格相当于是90块钱
对吧
因为他业绩增加了
然后一方面是三蜜的业绩价比较低
第二方面就是anthropic被formal了
就大家其实formal是anthropic
就是这个算力
然后加上算力的革命
然后大家需要无限的投肯
这个东西进行想想
然后第三是在半导体里面会看到很多的缺货
这个就是我们今天当我会说到的
就是我们接下来去做半导体的投资
或者是往后面投资往哪些方向去看
然后第一部分肯定是缺货
缺货导致他存储上没涨很多
但是本质上是市场上的头寸
在大规模的买卢
然后我们看到有很多的shadow
就是隐性的期权
不是不完全是隐性的期权
然后有很多隐性的方感
那么在这个过程当中
其实把那个半导体一直在往上推
包括我们看得到的一些copy的指数
我们先往后看一下
包括我们看到call cross spread的话
在3月上涨到后来
他的call和put skewness是完全被逆转
也就是大量的人在买路扣
然后买路扣以后
咱买路扣
然后有些人为了抄底还去卖put
所以这个过程当中
让put价格比较低
然后call价钱比较高
然后投行手上全是call
你涨的话
他们就要去买股票买证股
你买扣的话
比方说50%delta的话
那人家就要买50块钱的股票
对吧
那其实是在这个变相的
让市场在杠杆去买很多的证股
把整个市场推前
那么我感觉在前面几个因素其实没有错
但是市场的交易的因素
在半导体上上周应该是差不多结束了
就是在短期里面
就是直线的上涨
在短期里面都是要回调的
那么这周有一个有一个巨大的
恩尼报告就是那个英伟达
英伟达的恩尼肯定很好
然后Jason肯定会不拉不拉加很多
那个半导体巨大的需求
能不能再往前推
我觉得不太好讲
但是从上周五的交易的头寸来看
你看三米的就整个市场
就不是三米了
这个整个我们看到那个纳斯达克指数
纳斯达克指数最近已经跑到1.6倍的
那个上就是你那个收益除异
波动率跑到1.6倍
像像这样的上涨
其实直线的上涨
确实是对于AI token需要的认可
也确实是过去半导体的估值偏低
就整个半导体
估值偏低
再加上还有加上他的恩尼
他的业绩出来
确实证明了他估值偏低
因为后面给了很多的那个
forecast
干了很多预期
然后恩尼都不错
恩尼增加都很快
但是短期交易头寸是很危险
因为从上周五来看的话
一般来说
周五有很多option收盘
所以如果是call option的话
多的话
那个在伪盘的时候会有很多的买盘的
那上周五其实没有看到这样的买盘
然后再加上如果只看那个交易量的话
其实我们感觉很多的就周五左右
就上周四周五的话
有很多的option
他自己已经在开始被评判了
就是那个call option
一开始来评评评评判
然后lavage position
因为现在光靠lavage是很难推的动的
就是你还是需要有一些无脑的人
在那里无脑买
就比方说买call
你让那个头好那里对冲
那个是无脑买的
然后直接会把那个市场买上去
然后你网上涨的时候
他要买更多
那么因为那个上面是附干网
但是附干网现在也消失了
就是如果看那个call上面的附干网
基本上也消失了
所以网上涨的时候
他也不会无脑买
那么在这种情况下
就说我们觉得市场在短期交易上面
缺乏了那种前几个星期
former的时候那种无脑的买盘
如果仅靠retail
就散户闷
散户
然后加杠杆继续网上
那我觉得在短期里面
可能会风险更加大一点
因为你是如何急速的网上涨
你接下去要经过一些正常的调整
然后在半导体里面
缺货是肯定的
那么但是缺货这个事情
很后面缺少一些callist
缺少一些催化剂
就你在每次业绩的时候
你都可以说我缺货缺了很厉害
然后你没在业绩的时候
那个过程当中其实是有一些空撞期的
所以我的基本在短期里面判断
对于半导体的话
可能在一个如果是长期的话
如果是中长期
仍然是没问题
但是在短期里面的
在一个相对来说比较高的位置
就现在的话
半导体在一个比较高的位置
那么半导体的需求是真实的
再重访
这个需求是真实的
token需求也是真实的
但是同时的话
宏观上的风险也是真实的
就是我们现在并没有看到一个油价
快速的上涨
现在106万
我今天早上没注意看
然后大概在100块钱以上的油价
那么这个油价
其实并没有涨到
我们认为它应该够高的位置
也没有造成现在大规模的
这个需求的减少
那个油价的没有新高
有几方面云
第一个就是
政治上没有给出足够的预期
也就是比方说
川普经常跑出来讲
伊朗要核弹了
然后伊朗经常出来说核弹
虽然这个海峡还是关着
然后我大概少三个面吧
就是有条沙特的油管
可能可以走掉三个Million Barrel
原来那个运力大概20个Million
就是在2000万一桶每天左右
那以前在1400万
或者到1200万到1400万桶的减少还是有的
就基本上现在还是不通的
然后第一方面
政治上没有给出很明确的预期
川普一直在说我在核弹
然后伊朗方面就是反正坦坦地打
坦坦地打
他也没有直接开战
所以这个事情僵持着
然后给到市场一直有这个预期
然后包括那个
像狗们他们在做预期的时候
Base case还是觉得
5月份或6月份能够解封
但是实际解封的情况
包括中国也在给伊朗压力嘛
因为那个油价上升对中国的影响是很负面
因为中国又是伊朗很重要的支持者
然后但是实际上有可能
它的打开时间就是会变了很长
这是第一方面
但第二方面
因为有这个预期
然后大家在放出储存
就是我们现在的储存的存量上大的
就包括在中国的油的石油存量
包括全球的石油存量
包括在商业部门的大购物的石油存量
其实这一部分石油存量吸收掉了
应该有的价格成长
也就是如果说一开始就预期到
我们是绕到6月份不开
油价是肯定不会在100块钱
就是现在因为你漫水煮青瓜
你一直让它不打开
然后一直告诉他可能下周两周
那个川普说两周三周已经说了很多次了
所以你反而让这个油价
没有涨到一个很恐怖的位置
但是实际上对于海湾有十几个
Mb一天的减少
可能造成的demon disruption
需求的损害
然后可能造成的油价进一步的上涨
是超过这个价钱
就是应该要超过这个价钱
所以物理storage是另外一方面
然后我们在宏观市场上看到至少风险资产
5票资产和宏观产生的巨大的隔离
也就是上一个星期刚刚开始
我们才看到
因为上星期的催化其实是CPI吗
那个CPI和PPI两个都beat了
就是才看到
这个我们又直接贴那个trade view的
这是Cloud帮我画
但基本上数字是抓的trade view的数字
就是10年期的利率的上涨
10年期利率一直在往上涨
突破4.6了
现在那么30年好像是5.2 5.3万
30年我觉得不一定要作为一个很重要的参考
因为30年主要外加其实是对Pension Fund
或者一些长线的资金方采用
真正的市场看的风险是10年5年
就是说10年期破4.6
这是一个很危险的信号
我觉得10年期破4.6本身不一定对资本市场
造成很大压力
但是它共挣了10年期的波动率在上升
就是10年期的Wall上升
如果换成TLT
就换成标题资产
你们感觉可能会更加明显一点
换成标题资产打开3%的Wall上升
所以这个波动是非常大
你想股票现在贴资产多少
所以我们看到的是
就我们之前一直讲Rate对资本市场影响
相对来说不是那么对资本市场
至少对资本市场波动率的影响
没有那么极端
但是Rate Wall上升
是要你比较关注的一个东西
现在是Rate和Rate Wall都在上
然后这个在宏观上也是一个危险的信号
所以我们现在市场就分裂成两个
完全不同的派别
第一个派别是非常清晰的看到
其实我在两边都有了
就是第一个是非常清晰的看到
Token的需求
看到半导体直接导致生产力
所以半导体里面有无数的缺货
有各种各样的缺货
然后涨价
这是一方面
然后业界都会很好
业界的预期很好
然后第二方面
我们看到了宏观上面风险在加剧
特朗普访华之后
其实对于海峡没有指间影响
美国和中国确实是握手的
就是有很多的开放的东西
然后可能中美关系里面
中美国还开了新片
开了H200新片
除了H200新片
可能我觉得会实际上会开很多的
就是不是最先进之城
除了UEY的那些高科技的技术
可能都会有一些打开
都会放开一些
所以对中美关系和对中国高科技
肯定是利好的
偏偏想对于那些有些
比如说华为那些
那些不太利好
因为它原来是做爱国生意的
那个不利好
但是对大部分中国的高科节都是利好
但是宏观的风险没有解除
然后在市场的对于宏观风险
Vanus它的意识度在提高
那么意识度要提高
一方面反映在利率上
它本身的原因是上周出来的
CPI和PPI的数据比较差
那CPI和PPI质量数据
就我们看CPI的数据
CPI数据里面有一些
有一个很大的原因是房租上涨
那么房租上涨的
这个不太能够是长期的一个过程
首先房租这个东西本身就是有
那个
有 lagging 有有制后的
所以你这个中间房租其实
要看你过去一段时间的开工
那过去一段时间开工
前两年开工量算大
特别是在某些地区吧
然后整体的房租在美国
我觉得是很难有
本质的上涨的这个空间的
但是那个这次房租
其实上涨中间包括了前两次的调整
前两次那个CPI统计中间
没有很包含这个东西
所以PPI当然是上涨比较快了
这个油价直接带动
然后CPI中间有一些
那个比方说运输啊这些业在场
所以这两个数据把市场
吓到了
就是我们会不会进入一个通胀
先说一下我对基本面的一个判断
就是你在短期里面看
短期里面看这个CPI和
比方说我们现在比较关注的
PCIe吧
我看一下我有没有PCIe的图案
对
对 CPI和PCIe吧
然后
Cabin Wash也是看PCIe的
它只是说我看的是Ming和Million的PCIe
对吧
然后PCIe可能短期的数据
比CPI更加差一点
因为PCIe中间要包括一些软件
要包括一些硬件
比方说软件使用和硬件
那么因为AI
其实导致的PCIe可能会上涨更多
因为比方说Microsoft 360
它加了很多AI的feature在里面
然后它就涨价
然后软件也在涨价
然后硬件也在涨价
你看那个苹果的Max Studio
Max Studio现在就好像推出了
那个很少内存的版本了
对吧
我忘记是多少了
这32级还有多少
很少内存版本
那么它推出很少内存版本
其实英文内存位
所以AI其实是在跟Retail抢价格抢产品
就是我们AI行程生产力的同时
然后再跟Retail抢产品
抢价格
那么导致PCIe可能在短期里面要上升一些
所以在短期里面对于通胀的影响
然后油价的担忧
这个对于长短率压力是完大的
就是短期里面是有压力的
所以也让长短率率的那个
往往再上升
给市场其实在宏观里面造成了一些
造成了很多的困扰
那么在经济基本面上
但是经济基本面上看这个整体的需求
我觉得相反来说
我看你们需求
整体的需求来说的话
就那个就业反而不会特别好
那个就是从通胀里面三个方向
第一个shadow
那个房租
第二个产品
第三个公司
我们现在的经济体
是没有额物战争之前那种一点就然的通胀的基础的
也就是油价虽然上涨
但是通胀和PCIe的本身和特别是核心PCIe
它会上涨
它会传导性的上涨
但是它是传导性的
就是我们叫shock
就是它冲击性的上涨
它不是持续性的
可以有一个很大的通胀的基础
我们认为就是Wage Gross
其实你像Wage Gross才3.6
就是从一样业
年化的Wage Gross才3.6
然后在很多行业里面
特别是白领行业里面的就业
Job Open都不是特别好
所以你从就业来讲
我们在额物战争期间
因为美国的劳动参与率非常低
劳动参与率非常低的背后是政府发了很多钱
然后又有COVID
然后大家不工作很长时间了
然后白白可以拿政府的钱
为什么要工作呢
那么白白拿钱本身就财政政策
又是导致通胀
所以这个通胀的相当于温床
这个基础在这个财货就给你堆好了
然后油价一涨
就催化了整件事情
然后催化了所有的通胀上升
但是现在这些基础都不太存在
虽然Trump的移民政策比较严吧
但是他其实是没有赶回去多少人
对吧
然后实质
那个比方说很多高端人才去美国
还是开放的
就比疫情期间肯定少好很多
而且在拜登时期最后
其实引入了很多很多的移民
这个是一个
劳动参与率也会高很多
然后AI又其实是产生deflation
产生labor force deflation
产生劳动力的那个通缩
所以这几方面吧
然后中国现在出口是很正常的
那个产品商品端
商品端会有通胀
就是你石油会有通胀
但是现在贸易上面还是很通
中国在一个严重的通缩
通缩状态中间
包括我们看到上星期出来的
中国的这个retail数据
消费的数据
定那个雇投的数据
你别说中国高科技多好
股票涨涨什么样子
那个industrial production
就是这个工业工业制造数据
然后消费数据
固定资产投资数据都一大不同
所以这个都给美国或全球经济
贡献了一个通缩力
那么这个这几方面的基础上
就是说短期里面很难看到真正的通胀
那么短期晚一点的时候
今年晚一点
我觉得会看到什么的
就有可能会看到失业
这个才是我们市场就投资上面
要更加当心的东西
失业造成的有可能是通
这个通就是衰退的一个担忧
就是你一方面跟tariff一样
就是tariff会导致一些通胀
短期里面通胀担心
但是最后你看到了今年的时候
它是导致的经济
经济变差
现在我们的经济基本上的拉动
全是半导体拉动
也就是一个大的趋势
从人力的生产力到电子的生产力
到人工智能生产力
人工智能一方面抢你的饭碗
然后还抢你的内存
你能买到电脑一边过来
还抢你的内存
还抢你的各方面的这些资源
那种变贵了
你的CPI变贵了
所以这个我觉得是一个大的趋势
那么就说
我对整个市场的一个宏观的看法
就是在短期里面
就非常短期了
这几个星期
往上硬推动的能力再变弱
所以一个调整我觉得是很正常
而且是很应该的
这个是一个健康的调整
没有觉得这一轮会把它调回到比方
说3月份这样的下定
我觉得不太会
虽然它会deliverage 会去杠杆
但是我前面讲的AI的半导体的
就是在这一波业绩之后
很多东西都是真实的
它的需求是真实的
anthropic的业绩增长是真实的
anthropic的Ramil增长是真实的
所以从5月1号为转的话
5月1号之前
其实是包括CTA那些买盘给它硬卖上去
5月1号之后是业绩加FORM一起的
叫业绩加FORM加杠杆
然后加Option给它搞上去
所以如果一个正常调整
应该不是调到5月1号
是调到5月1号前的某个点
就是要把市场上的一部分的杠杆
要给它出境掉
那个半导体的杠杆出境掉
所以我觉得这个是一个比较健康调整
但是到你看就是宏观的风险
真正如果是在释放的话
宏观风险真正释放
甚至即使现在问题被解决
宏观风险在今年晚一点的时候被释放
就是我们加上衰退
然后加上这些大公司
CAPEXNECATIVE CASHFLOCK
CAPEX会变小
不是CAPEX变小
是市场预期它CAPEX没有办法达到买方预期
因为你毕竟复线金流的问题
复线金流
然后其实这些公司的CDS都已经杀伤了
复线金流CDS上升
那这些问题在今年晚一点发生共振的话
那么对于CAPEX这个担心的话
那么我觉得可能会有一个更好的一个机会
就是更长一点的
更长一点调整
然后我最后5分钟10分钟
因为其实宏观层面
宏观层面还有一个
就是CTA
我看我这边CTA的买卖
CTA现在是有一定的风险性的
这边好像没有写
我没有写CTA的
但是没关系
我觉得CTA现在其实是有一个风险性的
就是我们在未来一个星期大概会卖200亿
就是CTA大概会卖出200亿
涨的话也会卖200亿
那么跌的话大概300亿吧
这个数量不算特别大
你们记得5月1号的时候
我们叫Mense and Rebalance
Mense and Rebalance卖了230亿
但是市场一样给你缝抹上去了
对吧
它不是一个
这个量没有达到一定主导性
而且是Glob在美国的话100亿吧
但是如果下跌的话
它会卖很多
所以就是说它相当于给市场Pose的一个风险
如果下跌的话
它可以卖个Glob好像可以卖1000亿吧
就这个规模还是很大的
所以如果说真正在下跌的过程之中
如果是下跌的话
那么往下面的风险是tell risk是蛮大的
就是它会有一个伪布的风险
可以给你一把调到比方说5月之后的某个位置
这个是有可能性的
所以这个是要密切关注的
那我说一下另外几个
就是我们在做投资中间的一个
我觉得最近的一个机会吧
然后我们之前讲过
之前讲过我们要去投CAPAC
投资就是之前没有产能
现在因为投资产生产能
然后要去投追赶者
就是这个本质的背景都是AI的头衡的需求是无限
现在肯定是无限
所以你谁都缺货
那么我们就去投谁
现在市场上主流的投资
就是在半导体里面
叫投choking point
投卡脖子的地方
因为就好像一个水桶
你要去装很多很多水
整个市场没有预期过
要装这么多的水
所以你最后的短板
一定是最短的那块板
那个短板
那么choking point
就是在整个行业里面去找他缺什么东西
所以以前找到的就是缺存储
存储接下去会有长新的上市
然后市场会更多的谈论中国扩产能
扩到DDR去
然后虽然HBM中国也做不了
但是问题是DDR的产能
中国会扩展很多
然后这个会被讨论
所以choking point
就是像存储是最容易吵的
因为他一旦choking
他被那个卡脖子
他就涨价
然后涨价以后他的恶力马上就好
所以他是第一波吵最快
那么我觉得是两类投资
两个几回
一个我都多讲五分钟
一个是就是哪里是瓶颈
第二个是逆转
就是原来定价错误的逆转
就软件上定价错误的逆转
我觉得这个是两个今年能找到的机会
或者是我们关注的这个情况
在在那个短板里面
我觉得第二个就是光模块
就是光不光模块
就是光和光通讯
光通讯
大致的原因是
因为整个产业链很落后
然后过去呢
他不是适应于
比如说
你说卢麦腾
他们去做那个激光器
他过去并不是适用于去做大规模的
这算理中心的部署
所以现在的方案
不但要一代一代迭代
现在跌到CPU去
而且还要你起产能
就是他这个东西
他很难起产能过往
都不是这样起产能
你比方说在那个铃花银的那个维吾尔底层
那个在日本人家说缺货区的很厉害
对吧
有时候我增产30%
增产40%
对他们来讲已经很多了
这个整个行业没有经历过这样的
这个加产能的过程
所以其实如果你去看存储
存储是有扩产能经验的
他们过去每一次这个
每一次周期里面
都扩了很多产能出来
但是他扩产能是有经验
所以他的恩领会起来最快
等一下
他的恩领想法会起来最快
他盈利会起来最快
那么也会很快的把产能扩制的
但是在比方说在光和光通讯里面
他里面有很多的产能
他没有办法很快的扩制
所以这个赛道会跑的时间会更长
因为时间关系
我就说几个原因
比方说你在这个光芯片
你去做封装的时候
那封装产能有限
你检测电子去检测芯片
你很快
你检测光芯片就很慢
你要去调光
然后你怎么去对齐
你把CW laser放在芯片
Hyperbolic的芯片外面
然后你怎么去调光
又是问题
所以他在每一个环节里面
都会发生问题
其实发生问题都会变成Tropepoint
都会变成瓶颈
所以你在光整个赛道里面
会发生很多很多的机会
这是一个
其实第二个
我觉得更加对于
不需要去了解
好像也太多的人
一个很大的机会是软件的机会
就是大部分软件在AI时代
其实是属于一个
不是说被替代了
就是从C位降位的一个位置
C位降位的意思是说
我原来每年增长20%是固定的
我Discount Class
就是每年20
然后Discount回来
我的固执很高
但是AI出来以后
我的增长不能够达到过去
不是说你软件没用
而是说你软件
不是每一个软件都可以维持
原来的增速了
然后你的也不是说
你完全这个软件被替代
而是说你变成一个被雕用的东西了
那么有一些是获利的
它的增速会变
变得在AI时代变得越过去更高
然后大部分是不获利的
就是你的增速要下降
你原来你原来做税的
对吧
你做明确你做税的
那可见的未来你总是要被取代的
你举个例子
然后你有一些SARS软件
你去做
比方说Salesforce
那你可见的未来
你要不行的
但是有一些不是
有一些是在AI里面获利的
那么
所以现在市场有一个很简单的操作
就特别在Semi Leverage Up的时候
有一个很简单的操作
它就是去Long Semi
然后去Shout IGV
就是买那个半导体
然后刚才买半导体
然后就做空那个软件
因为软件是在AI里面
认为是失败者
然后半导体是个成功者
但这样的想法太简单了
在IGV里面有很多软件
直接是获利的软件
比方说Snow
Palentia
Oracle
那些都是获利的
Oracle肯定是获利的
因为人家是做算力的
对吧
它的软件
其实真二八截的软件收入
现在35%
然后不过
它有一部分的那个
云相关的这个软件收入
其实不能完全算成软件
它能够完全算成云的
对吧
所以其实它的那个
就是因为AI的算力中心
给它贡献的这个收入
已经比较超过50了
那么你认为Token不够
然后Token需求是无限
那么Token需求
到的第一站是谁
是到了第一站是云
就是到了他们手上
到了Amazon
到了Oracle
到了Metalsoft
到了那三家是对外
然后到了Google
对吧
然后它应该是到了他们手上
然后后面他们的采购
HyperScale的采购
然后再变成半导体
半导体直接变成
半导体是直接变Token
Token等于算力
是这么一个关系
所以IGV里面有一部分的公司
不应该是被无脑做空的
原来那个交易是有问题的
所以如果说真正以后去做多半导体
做空不应该是IGV
所以IGV我们叫做IGV Breakout
就是那个软件的这个指数
峰化是一个很大的情况
因为在软件指数被无脑空的时候
有很多好的公司
或者是在里面应该守护力的公司
它的估值一直被压着
上不去的
因为不行的时候就会
就会把你做空了
那么IGV Breakout的同时会发生什么
就是我们刚刚讲现在在发生的
三米的Delerage
就半导体的去杠杆
半导体去杠杆是肯定嘛
因为前面杠杆放太高了
整个市场流动性太多了
你可以看那个
我看有没有那个宽度
市场宽度
我忘了有没有
没有可能没放
你比方说上宽度有没有
但是整个半导体和那个SNP的指数的
这个关联度非常高
就SNP基本上都是半导体给拉上去
就这么说
SNP基本上半导体给拉上去
对吧
所以半导体的Delerage
可以和在IGV里面一些好的公司会
会拖印而出
这个是又是今年一个很大的
这个很大的情况
那么哪怕半导体不会去Delerage
不出问题
其实你反过来看在IGV里面
在那个在那个软件指数里面
它本身也是要去分化
所以我就说今年可能是在几个方向
就几个投资的逻辑
第一个就是我觉得在软件里面去
就软件里面找到AI真正获利的
然后在那个整个半导体里面去看
哪里有秋空 哪里有那个瓶颈
这个瓶颈很多
在特别的光里面瓶颈非常多
然后从金源加工到每一层
全是瓶瓶颈
然后第三个就是看追感者
和看那个CAPEX
就是谁以前做的投入
然后现在就会有产的吗
然后追感者原来买不掉
现在卖得掉
然后第三个看CAPEX就是效率
就是我投了CAPEX在哪里
投了CAPEX那个效果最好
那么这个大概是
这个大概今天我就讲这些东西
然后时间我用的比较长
我就你们要不要看看有什么问题
然后可以打出来